nous devons savoir pour le dîner dimanche
soir s'il vous plaît c'est un stupide d'
accord je vais le faire je vais couper un dîner avec
vous les gars ouais réveillez-moi quand vous rentrez à la
maison d'accord j'ai fait de beaux rêves Oh mademoiselle
Conway qu'est-ce qui vous fait penser que vos sœurs ont
été  enlevé ce gars est revenu pour moi
il est entré par effraction dans ma maison a pris ma sœur
parce que je n'étais pas là pourquoi reviendrait-il
pour toi je suis le seul à m'être
enfui parce que je connais son secret l'année dernière
un randonneur a repéré Joel couvert de  la boue
criant à propos de la façon dont certains gars l'ont
arrachée du lit, jetée dans un trou dans
les bois quelque part,
elle a dit qu'elle n'était pas la seule à avoir
des restes humains là-bas,
bien sûr, nous lui jetons tout
devinez ce que rien ne fait pas  existe il
va tuer Molly ce soir Jill tout est
dans ta tête rentre chez toi et dors
dors il est mort
j'ai besoin d'informations un crime a été
commis quel genre de voiture je voulais
juste savoir si tu as vu quelque chose d'inhabituel hey
tu as une femme folle  là-bas en agitant une
arme à feu fait-elle dr  op quelqu'un c'est sur nous
essayer de regarder julian tyler conway
ou bleu et blonde devrait être considéré comme
armé est un ange nous l'avons perdue il va
bientôt faire noir et molly va être morte
enterrée au fond d'un trou
avec toutes ces autres filles qui  personne
ne cherche
alors et si Jill n'est pas folle et si ce
gars a vraiment Molly
tourne ta main
qui est ce ouais je sais qui tu es